seriously indigeneity and transnational
rhythm the program in ethnicity racing
migration I would like to acknowledge
the Kennebec what I know he didn't
people as the traditional caretakers of
the land on which we're meeting and we
read and teach and live I would also
like to thank colleagues at rhythm
director stephen padeen
associate director of matthew Tenneco
and nicole edwards for their support and
assistance that it's made possible this
entire fall speaker series rhythm which
was founded in 2016 is the academic
research center that houses the
undergraduate program and ethnicity race
in life really I'd also like to thank
the chair of ethnicity race and
migration professor Alicia Schmidt
Camacho whoo-hoo lettuce last spring to
become an independent academic unit and
Margaret Homans and colleagues and
women's gender and sexuality studies who
are co-sponsoring our speaker today it's
my very great pleasure to introduce
Linda Mora who is professor of gender
sexuality and women's studies at
University of California Davis and the
director of the feminist Research
Institute there she previously taught at
UC Santa
the ethnic Studies department and was
affiliated with the programs in science
studies and critical gender studies
she's a leading scholar of globalization
bioethics and transnational women's
labor and her work on transnational
commercial surrogacy the global division
of care work and robotics and artificial
intelligence combine empirical and
cultural analyses speaking to the most
pressing issues in the humanities Social
Sciences and Natural Sciences her
analysis of the transnational
outsourcing of biological and effective
labor compels us to reconsider labor
theory of value but also the boundaries
and definitions of human life itself her
work has been recognized by
distinguished fellowships and
foundations including the University of
California president's post doctoral
fellows program the mellon Foundation
and the UC Humanities Research Institute
her first monograph graph life support
bio capital and new history of
outsourced labor exact published in 2015
by University of Minnesota press
examines the ways that both scientific
medical technologies and contemporary
forms of global outsourcing and
I have opened up the human body and
subjectivity for annexation harvesting
and exploitation considering human
tissue and organ sales commercial
surrogacy and varieties of care work
from domestic labor to call center work
she analyzes the commodification of not
only reproductive labor but effective
biological levels new sites of resource
and territory she emphasizes that the
accumulation of which opposed by a
capital like that a colonial capital
before it profits from an international
gendered division of labor plus these
forms of effective biological reductant
labor customarily under theorized or
overlooked in Western political economy
builds upon an earlier colonial
organization of production and her signs
of the present neoliberal globalization
villain divorce cooperative second
monograph with NATO konsovsky surrogate
humanity race robots and the politics of
technological futures published just
last year by Duke University Press
examines automation robots artificial
intelligence drones and other
technologies that serve as surrogates
for human workers within a labor system
that continues to uphold racial
capitalism patriarchy and Empire these
technologists demonstrate that even as
innovations promise revolutionary
liberation from labor inequality the
technologies are central media for this
reproduction of the various possessions
differences expectations that they
promise to transcend and remedy the
Lindiwe continues to work on
transnational assisted reproductive
technology analyzing clinics in India in
which different parties cultures and
social actors meet under radically
asymmetrical relations of color in her
essay co-authored with Malatya younger
citizen subjective property she
discusses the negotiations of
transnational and local actors in the
settings of an Indian clinic in which
the meaning and importance of
reproductive surrogacy transforms former
Indian understandings about kinship
heredity debt obligation embodiment and
community her current research continues
online riding on the legal and social
justice concerns connected to commercial
surrogacy ongoing studies of feminist
approach to start official intelligence
and robotics and a book project on
anti-capitalist structures of care and
responsibility social reproduction
and social reproduction please join me
in welcoming professor
lady Bora who will speak today on
inefficient feeling okay care as
revolutionary praxis on the end of
society good afternoon everyone thank
you so much for being here I understand
that there are a lot of other things
competing for your time and attention so
I'm pleased that you can make it I'm
just going to go ahead and start in July
of 2016 a team of multidisciplinary
scientists and aerospace engineers based
at nasa's langley center published a
paper proposing a project to study the
potential for human reproduction on mars
they're calling it the
multi-generational independent colony
for extraterrestrial habitation autonomy
and behavior or my sub the short term
goal of the experiment is to send a
mouse colony into orbit to study how
space flight and partial gravity impact
health and birth rates over three
generations a proposed 600 cameras would
observe the colony whose care would be
charged to earth controlled teller
robots the concept video which I'll show
a clip of in a moment compares the
experiment into the Lewis and Clark
expedition as it is designed to scout
for the possibility of establishing a
human base version for a Mars colony I'm
going to show you two very brief clips
hopefully the sound works to give you a
sense of the imaginary behind the
project
NASA is currently designing approaches
to explore Mars with an emphasis on a
pioneering approach similar to the Lewis
and Clark expedition worried the
spacecraft will be designed to support
the growth of a large mass colony for
your long durations studying
reproduction and maturation of the
interior consists of multiple levels of
specially designed bounce enclosures
which can be removed from the main
cylindrical structure for cleaning and
maintenance the colony maintenance robot
house of a spanner adjustable platform
services enclosure the habitat is
designed to autonomously support the
mice throughout their lifecycle mice can
be selectively bred to create
generations which have only lived in
partial gravity while remaining over
breeding these future generations can be
observed to understand the million
reproductive challenge
physiological changes and other
behavioral characteristics this facility
can also address other human exploration
research goals including collecting data
on how the radiation in deep space
affects human health the systems onboard
the facility will also be tested to
benefit the development of human systems
including the demonstration of
autonomous robotic maintenance and
long-duration operations in a deep space
environment so reproduction through
generations of mice is a time-tested
structure for laboratory studies of
genetic and epigenetic change mice hub
is a model study for human reproduction
where the model of genetic change over
generations in a lab like setting I will
argue necessarily engages a history of
capture the capture of human
reproduction as a source of wealth
through colonial and chattel slavery
economies and its eventual translation
into eugenics and population science
many of us in the field of ethnic
studies have been following the
discourse on Mars colonization which has
mounted with the evidence of the climate
change of Earth the earth the model of
revolutionary change in this imaginary
embraced and promoted by techno elites
like Richard Branson and Elon Musk is to
leave a dying planet to reproduce life
elsewhere bringing the same historical
formula of the human and its
reproduction through generations along
with them in my past work I've argued
that the antecedents of contemporary bio
economies which rely on being able to
patent innovative knowledge and to
exploit the undervalued and often
invisible reproductivity of humans and
other organisms as well as of their
parts like tissues and cells were
present in the katakana mieze of
colonialism and chattel slavery in which
dehumanized and unfree workers were also
self reproducing capital for me the mice
hub project imagines a continuation of
this logic into future technological
infrastructure that will also continue
to influence the structure of the human
subject and of society so my research my
current research looks at the
imaginaries of both
radical change and human Futurity
implicit in the design of new
technologies and considers alternatives
to ask how do we work with the world we
have given its historical roots in
colonial science reproductive science
and our limited models for sustainable
relations of care to forward a different
model of human all together this
question has come out of my two book
length studies and the third
ethnographic study which professor Lowe
introduced so elegantly which
scrutinized the social and technological
infrastructures through which we
understand reproduction as labor and as
a biological process specifically I'm
interested in the relationship between
technology design and alternative
socialities of care seeking models that
generate effects of social solidarity
beyond the possessive individual and
nuclear family I'll explain how this new
research direction is pro science and
for technology but inspired by
historical critiques of techno
imaginaries and radical models of change
that have their roots in women of color
feminism I'll do this by way of some of
the building blocks for this inquiry
that are reflected through some of my
previous work so in the recent book
surrogate humanity which is co-authored
with Nita a tone osofsky
we critique technologies designed to
replace humans and automation in warfare
in looking at the development of
automation technologies we briefly
discuss the influence of Charles
Darwin's writing about human emotion on
the design of social robots in the late
1990s this history is helpful in
connecting the histories of colonial
scientific exploration and the my sub
project so it's part of cross connecting
those two that I'm going to work on with
you now specifically it shows how
technologies are designed to underwrite
the feeling of autonomy and mastery for
the liberal subject what in this book we
call the surrogate effect of technology
so Darwin's writing on emotion and
evolution precisely captures the moment
when modern scientific knowledge
establishes the post enlightenment
liberal European subject as self
identical with the category of human for
Darwin those who are quote
DeVries enlike animals the insane and
those recent races distant from European
man become brute and character as they
are reduced to base emotion in quote he
explained that these primordial habits
are the basis of our evolution as a
species but became vestigial now that
Europeans had overcome them through
civilization to represent the apex of
humanity this Institute's what
philosopher Sylvia Wintour calls the
ontology of man she argues that to
escape the ongoingness of the colonial
scientific project requires us to quote
read ascribe the human the design
prototype in social robotics is Cynthia
Brazil's robot kismet and by the way I'm
happy to talk about any of these
examples in the Q&A I'm just going
through them briefly kismet was designed
on a model of infant caregiver
interaction and programmed with
affective drives robot assists Brazil
traces her understanding of the neural
architecture of human emotion to
Darwin's 1872 proposal that the quote
emotive signaling functions were
selected for during the course of
evolution because of their communicative
efficacy hizmet's programming and
hardware are organized around the
processors input devices and hardware
required to animate its face kismet SPRO
Graham drives modeled on Darwin's
biological drives determine the robots
performance of an emotional state which
you saw a little bit there so Cynthia
breazeal who's in this picture as a PhD
student Brazil's approach to emotionally
expressive robots equates evolution with
the ability to perform the existence of
an interior psyche to the outside social
world kismet affirms the superiority of
the human subject who interacts with it
by performing a lack of interior t why
is this a problem because this lack of
interior T is the crystallization of a
racialized colonial premise that
presumed so-called primitive people's
could not screen their performance of
emotion like the juvenile humans on
which the kismet system is based like
the mice hub project kismet is a
prototype for a large-scale
technological infrastructure
whose unstated premise is that
technology should affirm the humanity of
the user by assuring the human of their
autonomy and superiority this reasserts
a human subject that believes in the
equivalence of mastery with autonomy and
fails in Sylvia winters words again to
read ascribe the human in its social
worlds
instead it replicates a singular social
scientific imaginary of what the human
is and what it can be because of its
basis in Darwinian logic this history of
cynthia brazil's impact on social
robotics is an example of how more often
than not technology designers
uncritically reproduce prejudicial
histories into infrastructure that then
carry forward the same burden version of
the human as most of you know Darwin's
half cousin and contemporary Francis
Galton developed his highly influential
eugenic reasoning out of the same mix of
scientific exploration and colonial
conquest that fueled Darwin's studies
the origin of the species was a
particular inspiration for Galton whose
work in eugenics became the origin point
for what would develop into population
science the s-curve statistical model
for population growth which is what
you're looking at was developed by
American biologist Raymond pearl in the
1920s and was based on his fruit fly
studies as part of the Galton lab at
University College London by the 1970s
population science had grown to shape
the policies of developmental
consultants and funders like US aid and
the IMF who dictated that governments in
the decolonizing world produced
population growth as curves that looked
like this sculpting the life
possibilities of entire developing
nations including averted births and
permitted deaths through mass scale mass
scale famines and epidemics that could
have been prevented by government
intervention this allowed population
science to collude with racial
capitalism and as Lisa Lowe says in the
book the intimacy's of four continents
identify particular regions for
production and others for neglect
certain populations for exploitation and
others for disposal as mr. Murphy argues
in her book the economies
of life population science put
reproduction at the center of how
capitalism summons its world in my first
book life support I look at how as part
of colonial racialization India's
residents were figured as numerous
easily replaceable and best suited for
reproduction my study illustrates how
this discourse of race and India and
particularly of Indian workers as
numerous and best suited for
reproduction becomes transformed at
different moments of history yet remains
in the structuring of the global labor
market today to assign social and
biological reproduction work to India I
discussed changes in the Indian labor
market during the global economic shift
of the 1990s which centered flexible
production technology innovation and
scientific research on reproductivity
and as dr. Loe mentioned in the
introduction this period is referred to
as a shift to bio capitalism feminists
science studies scholars have defined
bio capital as a form of extraction that
involves isolating and mobilizing the
primary reproductive agency of specific
body parts rather than focusing only on
biological science and biotech as sites
for producing value my study looks for
the social logics within biological and
labor markets for evidence of how
capitalist accumulation has historically
and continues to rely on reproductivity
based on ethnographic data on call
centers computer programming and
gestational surrogacy the book argues
that bio capitalism and any analysis of
bio capital must engage its roots in
colonial labor allocation as a project
of the racializing and gendering of
weber and oops i gave you a sneak
preview my field to work for this book I
did two field projects one took place in
Bangalore India in 2005 and six and the
second took place in northwestern India
in a gestational surrogacy clinic in
2008 so both of those inform this book
and after completing it and the separate
publication of some of the empirical
research in the surrogacy clinic in a
separate set of article
I realized that surrogacy was in fact a
more general form of a social
relationship that included but was not
limited to actual gestational surrogacy
it was also a more expansive social
relationship where surrogate indicates
an object or subject that supplements
another subject this relationship can be
found everywhere from colonial indenture
and slavery to the programming of
emotive response and social robots like
the one I just show you and I'll explain
so from the vantage point of the study
of the long history of this capture of
reproductive lives and labor and the
service of accumulation the autonomy of
the liberal subject looks like a ruse
this dependence on invisible and
self-reproducing hands that serve
remains an unscrutinized component of
technological design imaginaries the
liberal subject cannot exist without
human and increasingly technological
surrogates which became apparent to me
through the role the central role played
by technology in each of my studies so
as I was finishing this book I'll go
back to the ethnography with information
tech workers in Bangalore in two
thousand five and six I found their
frustration that they raised with being
unable to do what felt like creative
work the generation of new code and new
platforms that was specifically targeted
for an Indian audience I found this
frustration reflected in what was that a
growing digital labor marketplace so
this was again the frustration with only
having access with the data equivalent
of service work cleaning up code that
someone else wrote reproducing projects
that were invented in other countries
for other markets rather than interests
in India in fact around that time in
2012 lilly irani a computer science and
scientist an SDS scholar told me about
Amazon Mechanical Turk which I'll refer
to as AMT in relation to that earlier
research the AMT internet marketplace is
a software platform where employers can
post what are called human intelligence
tasks
with a price price for each task just
out of curiosity have any of you
participated as either a requester or a
Turk in this economy no one would admit
sometimes people have in the world of
coding and online retail programmers
continue to struggle to come up with the
holy grail of artificial intelligence
that is software that can use algorithms
to categorize the seemingly infinite
amounts of user-generated data we have
so personal photos rants in the
blogosphere kitni humor all these things
that we generate to translate those into
value producing datasets for e-commerce
a 2016 Q survey found that half of
turkeys make less than five dollars an
hour even working full-time and in 2010
AMT was utilizing mainly workers from
the US and India so there was a direct
correlation between the kind of
reproductive data service work happening
in India in real-time and also online
AMT is a recent technology that was
considered revolutionary in the world of
e-commerce and informatics and which I
also find the issues of reproduction
gendering and racialization very
apparent but it engages subjects who
don't fit within a stable identity based
model whether that be national ethnic or
class found the extension of the
politics of difference and of subjection
into the realm of the digital whereas
Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos once joked and he
provides humans as a service is a
problem that we take up in the book
surrogate humanity ante is obviously an
example of a new iteration of
outsourcing and outsourced work which is
composed of nodes in the production
process that are generally understood to
be non innovative and therefore
reproductive is generally devalued even
though it enables the high valued and
much more high compensated creative and
innovative labor that makes an election
intellectual production centers like
Silicon Valley possible Silicon Valley
would not exist the way it does now
without crowdsourcing work like Amazon
mechanic
Terk and this relationship is much like
the way that marxist feminists described
the role of reproductive labor in the
home and I came home as an economic unit
where the gendered labor of the wife
reproduces the humanity of the worker
who goes into the public sphere so
technologies like AMT provide new ways
to think about the relationship between
gender and labor as the historical
gendering of what is deemed non creative
and non innovative reproductive work is
the essential work for the success of
startups who reap its benefits yet still
that reproductive work carries forward
this negative valuation that comes from
its origin and the private sphere so the
surrogate effective technologies like
the surrogate effects of reproductive
labor in the household as I'm going to
go into in a moment or in the commercial
surrogacy clinic itself where I kind of
first put these things together is to
again underwrite the supposed autonomy
of the liberal subject even while
performing the necessary invisible labor
that makes this experience of mastery
and autonomy possible in the first place
so now I'm going to take up the
surrogate effective reproductive labor
and technology in the surrogacy clinic
to show how surrogates as workers and
subjects themselves point to ways too
radically reconsider sociology and
relationality
mmm so at the menisci clinic where I did
my 2008 ethnographic research
commissioning mothers which is the legal
term for the intended parent so
commissioning mothers and sometimes
fathers were invited into the embryology
lab and sterilized suits and masks to
view the forming embryo under the
microscope on day two following
conception at which point is called the
blastocyst and obviously this would
never happen in the u.s. one of the
directors of the clinic explained that
this helps commissioning mothers bond
with the fetus it's not even an embryo
yet the very idea that there is
something with which to bond here
depends on the externalization of the
developing embryo from the uterus of the
gestational surrogate but also the
microscope is instrument and the
visualization and discourse of the fetus
as it will develop into a subject in its
own right there's a lot going on in this
bonding moment right
DNA from parental gametes and the
parental intention that's bound into the
surrogacy contract explains who is
supposed to bond with the cells under
the microscope genetics is a ssin is a
process by which genetics has come to
explain health and disease and to
naturalize social difference as
biologically based and it operates and
seems like the one I just explained to
you to naturalize genetic descent as
legitimate parentage and egg donors and
surrogates as providers of what Melinda
Cooper and Kathryn wall B have called
services in the self that is services
that rely on in vivo biological
processing and the utilization of the
workers living substrate as elements as
essential elements in the reproductive
process as a metaphor DNA implies a
hierarchical ordering so that the
intended parents as the source of DNA
have more right to control the process
of surrogacy than the surrogate herself
because they are positioned as creative
authors of the fetus and legally
speaking the fetus is more like their
property than anything else the
surrogate is
and opposition figured legally as a
service provider in the contracts so in
the articles I've written out of this
ethnographic study I've talked about how
visualizing technologies like the
microscope but also ultra sonography and
obstetrics marginalize the pregnant
person and render them as purely bodily
labor and passive bodily labor
empowering the genetic and property
claims of commissioning parents to the
infant born through surrogacy I've also
written about how this informs how
surrogates are compensated with very low
wages in comparison to the other costs
of surrogacy but also very minimal
health entitlements and these are
conditions that haven't changed over
time because this study was in the ER in
2008 through 2016
so in embryology labs like the one I
just described infertility clinics like
menisci we can see practitioners working
towards manifesting world views
imaginaries into futures worldviews that
imagine away the body and nurture work
of the so called gestational carrier in
favour of the lovable blastocyst under
glass and the isolated fetus that we see
in ultrasound imaging and there's a vast
literature on this and feminist Science
and Technology studies that we can talk
about if you want to mm and my ongoing
research on assisted reproductive
technology as well as technologies that
capitalize on making reproductive labor
invisible and under compensated so for
example Amazon Mechanical Turk I've been
studying how technologies and the
economies of social reproduction require
us to not only scrutinize new physical
relationships between bodies but also to
see the contest over how new socialities
are forming around these technologies so
there's a power struggle going on it's
not simple cut and dry process and as
the examples from the embryology lab and
in that s-curve in population studies
that I showed you as these are meant to
illustrate such world views have
important political content when we
think about how technologies and their
governance can materialize one
particular reality or worldview over
others and how being the subject of
medical risk or resource extraction
usually means not having access to
influencing how technologies
materialized features so in my research
on the global outsourcing of this work
of care service and even childbirth I've
continued to look for and find practices
that challenge the reproduction of
racialized and gendered norms of family
also the household economy and the
gendering and sexual practices that go
with them for example in the late 80s
and early 90s when India took an
International Monetary Fund loan to
stabilize its currency and started
instituting the structural adjustment
policies that paved the way for
outsourcing feminist scholars were
starting to publish critiques of the
then still relatively new imaging
technologies and obstetrics that I just
kind of touched on briefly at the same
time world leaders began focusing on the
individual and the family as key
economic units for state policy not a
coincidence but a central part of the
shift away from the social welfare state
which is what I want to talk about
briefly now in 1987 Margaret Thatcher
famously encapsulated a new historical
feeling the feeling of being a
neoliberal subject when she said quote
there is no such thing as society there
are individuals and there are families
and klee I want to point out two things
that are happening in Thatcher statement
first
it's a Fantasma gram a Fantasma gram
according to historian of science
Michelle Murphy explains how large
abstract concepts describing the social
world then bring themselves into
existence by guiding human practice and
Murphy says that the economy the macro
economy these are Fantasma grams
abstract ideas that guide our behavior
to actually make them material mm-hmm
the free market was a fiction in which a
strong belief commanded the building of
infrastructures policies and behaviors
less obvious are the effective
infrastructures brought into being as a
result of this Fantasma graham of the
free market
here for example Thatcher's individual
and Families as an alternative reality
to social collectivity which is one way
to think about the move for a social
welfare seat the second thing that
Thatcher's statement does is assert the
end of society as a collective project
that is the end of social solidarity mmm
the modern nuclear family as an ideal is
a relatively recent invention a set of
people living together in one household
economic unit which is recognized
through tax reporting shared medical
insurance social school enrollment death
benefits visitation custody rights etc
in reality of course most households do
not match this imaginary of the nuclear
family and in his book about early 20th
century San Francisco titled contagious
divides historian nyan Shah described a
set of intimacy's and domesticity z'
that did not replicate the idealized
capitalist citizens subject forming at
that time which was the white
middle-class nuclear family in its
residents Shah called these queer
domesticity z' he looked at several
examples including bachelor immigrant
households but we can include
contemporary examples like coops blended
families single mothers who swapped
childcare on an informal basis
grandparents housing and supporting
adult children and grandchildren and so
forth yet the state continues to offer
full rights and social welfare benefits
those little that remain only two
families constructed through a legal
marriage contract or I should say
primarily to I think queer domesticity
z' refused to reproduce the nation I'm
not celebrating them as they are also
often testimony to the fact that low
resource contexts lead to creative
living solutions that arise because the
state refuses to recognize them as
legitimate sites for rights and social
welfare entitlements but for today we
can look at these queer domesticity zazz
protesting the reproduction of the
nation because they destabilized that
white nuclear family norm and I'm just
going to take a minute to talk a little
bit about how feminist theorists have
talked about the household as an
economic unit so scholars including
Maria mise Carol pavement and John
Jacobson have argued that marriage the
states preferred way of recognizing
domesticity and family has also
historically been a labor contract
specifically a labor contract that
creates the subordinated economic
position of life within the household
unit of course women of color feminists
including Angela Davis
Evelyn Nakano Glen Sheila Sandoval
Dorothy Roberts bell hooks among many
others have pointed out that immigrant
and low-resource women have always done
their own household labor plus underpaid
work in the households of wealthier
often white families historically so
Marie amis and her book patriarchy and
the accumulation of capital says that
the marriage contract was what made the
nuclear family possible creating a new
historical economic domestic form which
replaced wages for labor with marriage
love would now be the compensation for
labor in the household no wages Janet
Jakobsen explains how the household
economic unit has also helped support
the fiction that the liberal subject is
free and autonomous she says this
freedom is a fiction because it relies
on the subordination of invisible lives
and devalued support labor historical
male head of household could not survive
without the labor of wife children
servants and slaves erased through the
marriage contract as well as the strict
limits on what counts as family under
the law
mieze goes on to explain that the modern
marriage contract set up a model of
unpaid labor in the private sphere of
the home that is then extended through
globalization to encompass the formerly
colonized world label labor economies so
we can add casualized labor including
many forms of crowd-sourced digital work
clicking empty sweatshop work customer
service call center work all extend from
the model of unpaid and underpaid labor
in the gendered private sphere these
forms of labor have little in common
except they are pro and they're
performed sorry they have little in
common except they are deemed to be
uncreated or reproductive and therefore
while they're performed by people of any
gender the work itself is feminized
and this is the process that in the late
70s me is called housewife ization which
doesn't roll off the tongue but makes
sense now I want to talk about one
particular example of how gendered labor
gets superimposed onto the formerly
colonized world from my research on
transnational surrogacy surrogacy is one
of one example of an outsourced labor
market of course one that follows the
map of colonialism to provide the
support labor that helps make the
seemingly autonomous citizen subject
seem possible at all I mentioned earlier
that I had done field work with
international participants and an Indian
assisted reproductive technology clinic
in early 2008 and at that point the
practice was still very new in India
there are only a few clinics offering
the service and people outside of India
were just starting to hear about it I
followed the development of what then
grew to become what some called in
industry tracking legal debates draft
legislation feminist organizing and
policy work in India as well as
discussions in Europe in the US about
the ethics of becoming commissioning
parents because these are the places
where most commissioning parents were
come from coming from at one point when
I was spending my days in the clinic I
was asked to step in for one of the two
doctors who was translating for a
conversation between a woman who
intended to be a surrogate and a man who
intended to Commission a surrogacy
so the commissioning father from New
York named David and the surrogate the
intended surrogate is named Pushpa so
after they're introduced the doctor
walks off and I should say that David
was using and his wife who did not come
on this trip we're using donated eggs
and Pushpa the surrogate is here
exploring the attempt in extent of his
intentions towards her and her family
she asked if he would be willing to
bring her family to the US and help them
find jobs this is quite early in the
conversation and he's of course a bit
startled he says something like oh yes
of course you know I want to help you
educate your children and maybe yeah
maybe someday something you could come
to the US perhaps but by the end of
their contract nine months later he
described his insurmountable frustration
with her continued
- as he said get more money from him and
his wife every time they communicated I
found a general insistence among women
who had previously been surrogates or
were currently when I was there that it
should be common sense that
commissioning parents would want to have
a responsibility to them indefinitely
after that child is born so this was
coupled with an idea of the idea that
surrogacy is something yes it's a
contracted form of service or labor but
it's also much more than what money
could represent and actually in my work
I talk about how there's a precedent for
this kind of relationship between
someone with sort of minimal resources
and power in society and someone with
much greater resources and power in
society when the lower position person
does something great for the person more
power that person is responsible for the
other person indefinitely so there's a
historical precedent for this and as I
mentioned before the work of care
nurture and attention in biological
gestation and biological destination and
surrogacy is devalued because it's
gendered not just because women do it
but because the services as work are
gendered it's outsourced to racialized
nations like India and performed by
their citizens as underpaid labor but
you know thinking back to nyan Chows
study Oh queer domesticity 'z again in
1930 San Francisco I want to think about
how this moment in the clinic also
suggests that the work of care could
lead to new forms of sociality and maybe
even lead us to think about how
institutions can change so the notions
of family have actually been shifting in
response to mostly lawsuits regarding
surrogacy practices transnationally so
we're in the process and right now in
contemporary life of figuring out what
it means to be able to mix bodies and
social the social meaning of family in
these ways so can we think of the
assertion of some surrogates that they
should have a lasting connection to the
families they contracted with for a
surrogacy really the
understood as absurd or impossible so
it's the kind of question to hold
because that's how it was framed in the
clinic by doctors a commissioning
parents this isn't this is a nine-month
contract it's not a forever contract
referencing women of color feminism and
queer of color critiques as examples
Grace Hogg and Rod Fergusson argue that
develops that devalued subjects and
social relations require new analytics
through which to apprehend coalitional
possibilities or what they call strange
affinities I see the repeated statement
by surrogates that they should feel that
they feel they should be in an ongoing
reciprocal relationship with
commissioning parents as a call for
those parents to think about a
collective investment could we imagine
models of recognizing collectives that
can replace social and legal recognition
of just the family models that could
destabilize the privileges of some
citizens and subjects over others models
that would challenge the power relation
of the social contract the marriage
contract the surrogacy contract as we
know many people are also already living
in collectives those queer domesticity
is that the nation has tried to warn us
away from so my current work pursues the
questions I've set up for you today what
other possible forms of sociality care
and relation can we open up through
rethinking specifically here techno
scientific infrastructures and I'm just
going to tell you a little bit about
some of the projects I'm working on now
so my current research aims to not only
analyze the structures I've described
but to change them I'm going to briefly
talk about ways I've aligned
marginalized scientific research with
marginalized social voices in my work
and also have found ways to directly
impact STEM fields by presenting key
issues in science and technology to an
audience that's directly impacted by
these but often excluded from debates
and as I mentioned before to go back to
this surrogacy clinic question the women
who participate in surrogacy have not
described their role as simply or as one
dimensionally as have social
representation
of surrogacy which often talk about
wombs for rent right and there are
medical and legal correlations with that
where the surrogate is positioned as a
temporary service provider surrogates
don't describe their oldest way I
mentioned that many surrogates had said
they felt their influence on this
developing embryo and fetus was
permanent and that commissioning
families should therefore an experience
and enduring connection to them and
their families through a sense of
something like responsibility that would
defy this genetic logic of connection
that only happens through DNA I talked
about genetics is a shin so I in
response to this kind of call I saw it
in found research in a mean ology that
validates the biological reality behind
what surrogates were expressing so one
example of that is a phenomenon called
fetal cell micro Kaymer ism and I can
talk about this again more in the Q&A
it's a field of research that was
actually marginalized itself until the
last 10 years and even though it's been
around since the 70s and in immunology
it explores the exchange of cells
between the gestational body and the
fetal body during pregnancy cells
actually do go back and forth across the
placental barrier which people didn't
know until the 70s and ignore it until
the 90s this exchange occurs in both
directions between the fetus and the
gestational body and the cells continue
to circulate in both bodies for years
after the delivery and as Susan
Elizabeth Kelly notes the discovery of
this phenomenon challenges the notion of
the immune self which is the basic
tenets of immunology but on an
ontological level it also challenges the
previous biological understandings that
we have of this barrier between the
pregnant person and the fetus and that's
a Barratt barrier that not only
maintains the separate biological cells
but correlates to this idea of the
separate legal bio legal individual
based in genetics is a ssin and DNA so
it can test the understanding of
individuals as discretely bound organism
and for gestational surrogacy whose
model of legal parental rights is
mediated through geneticist and property
there's a servants of this nature
culture category of the bio and social
self uses an argument based in DNA
against geneticist
some supporting arguments that
surrogates make about their influence on
the developing fetus it also supports
this extended timeline that surrogates
assert for their effect on the mature of
the fetal and maternal bodies on one
another
so as I mentioned in the time since
completing surrogate humanity a few
years ago I've moved some of my research
agenda to impact STEM fields directly
through the pedagogy and practice of
technology design as director of the
feminist Research Institute at UC Davis
I've been able to steward social change
oriented stem projects by funding
collaborative groups that bring together
expertise and feminist research and
ethnic and community histories on the
one hand with technical expertise on the
other so for example I'm Co P I with dr.
Sarah McCullough
on a National Science Foundation grant
called innovations and graduate
education and we're developing new
curricula for for science and
engineering departments to train PhD
students to incorporate historical
injustice and exclusions into their
assessment of the design impact of their
studies and final projects so here's one
visual representing the challenges to
feminist stem and then visions for what
it can be so based on a year-long
working group process an advisory board
feedback we're currently designing and
testing three levels of curriculum for
graduate students that uses the insights
of feminist science and technology
studies and ethnic studies to Train
current PhD students to consider
histories like those I've shared today
as these work as they work to imagine
what kind of technology infrastructures
we can build to enable a different
future so again working with world views
and imaginaries which is something that
people in social sciences and humanities
are well trained to do is actually
something that can be used in stem and
to build a larger community around this
NSF research we've started a
subcommittee within the Society for the
social study of science that's dedicated
to feminists and technology so it's not
even just at UC Davis and I'm also one
of three senior researchers on a team of
11 authors who've written a book
manuscript called techno precarious
which is a bit of a lofty title but I
kind of like it and techno / curious
includes a chapter on care as a
methodology a political methodology and
a research methodology based in the
University of Michigan security lab the
book takes up the problem of new forms
of procure decreed by technology
including extraction economies the
failure of mainstream medicine to meet
trans health needs the negative impacts
of automation on Medicare and Medicaid
among many other topics and we look at
these through both policy based thinking
and also models of collectives and care
that can address some of these failures
and as with the book techno / curious
framework secure structure the analysis
and political stakes of another example
of my current work as the convener of a
10-week residential group at the
University of California Humanities
Research Institute I got to work with a
group of social scientists who study
science and technology and also like me
collaborate with scientists in their
research and after 10 weeks of sort of
working together and hosting our
collaborators we co-wrote what we are
calling a pocket guide to feminist
science whereas the NSF project aims to
build curriculum to train stem
researchers and feminist approaches the
pocket guide is meant to be used in the
field in other words it's written as a
short introduction to the problems of
non feminists of non feminist approaches
to science as well as providing some
entry-level tools for feminist practice
care and research practice is one of our
central analytics and this is just the
introduction to that chapter the tone is
meant to be light and fun so that a
variety of people can actually engage it
but our first chapter actually starts
with introducing the Imperial history of
scientific exploration and I can come
back to this slide and talk about it
during the Q&A coming to a bookstore
near you
okay so technologies of reproduction and
care are poised to redefine the human
and our social fabric the mice have
example we began with is a technology of
imagine colonization proposing to
populate a new space with
self-reproducing generations an
imagination that comes out of a failed
and dangerous the filled in dangerous
logics of eugenics population science
and technologies of reproduction that
have been by design
meant to subjugate the majority of
humans and service of capital
accumulation and the fiction of autonomy
for a few we obviously need new models
for interdependent human care to enrich
our technological imaginaries these
models would necessarily think outside
of nation family or even the human my
critiques along with those of other
feminist science and technology scholars
like Rijo Benjamin who I know is just
here Kim tall bear Angie Willie these
are a call for attention to the role of
social reproduction and carrying forward
histories of genocide slavery and
colonialism and science attention that
can inform the new design of new social
and technological infrastructures to
help read ascribe the human at the end
of society whether this is due to the
threat of planet wide extinction or
simply the unfurling of Thatcher Ian's
anti mutual aid individualism care that
underwrite social solidarity has to
hedge risk to the welfare and comfort of
the liberal individual for me a response
to the critique of technology design
I've presented today must overcome a
deep denial of interdependence a denial
that serves the long and oppressive
history of the liberal subjects
dependence on false proof of its own
autonomy thank you
[Applause]
and I'm ready to do questions or
show-and-tell whichever so in the book
surrogate humanity I think they might be
asking about Alesi blind moms new book
but they're not here so we can't know so
for me I would say that in the book
surrogate humanity we start with Cydia
Hartman's observation historically that
the relationship between master and
slave and that relationship to slave
apartments has functions as a surrogate
self for the master and actually we
start with that observation because it's
a fundamental social and economic
relationship upon which American racial
capitalism is founded and because that
model is structuring the the literal
political economy of what we're now
analyzing we start there so the notion
of the surrogate relation actually
begins with see the apartments work and
the book ends with portents pillars work
on what it means to ungentle to to have
no gender when you're talking about
bodies and we think about this kind of
imaginary in the development of
technologies that are supposed to do
everything that a person does socially
to be animated like we actually talk
about sex robotics to be animate to the
objects of desire to even simulate
consent and the reciprocation of desire
yet to be absent of a subjectivity
and we wonder where does that desire
come from and we think alongside of
black feminists and the work they've
done on the captive reproductive body
the under captive reproductive body to
think about where that desire comes from
and we don't reach any conclusions but I
would say that that's how some of these
specific black feminist scholars have
shaped some of that thinking yeah
Challenge is really about temporality I
was just a little bit they are where
they are enough kids yeah so it make you
stay and my question is about this month
I have to confess I'm working at a
project I started I'm just starting a
project under race and rain washing and
batons and so that was really
interesting to see I would love an
amicus with his name to get some it as
an acronym and I think the I thought
what I saw was
okay I knew backwards
I saw that so if you want to see kismet
it's physical forum you can go to the
MIT Museum and their robot their
permanent robotics display has four
kismet taken in two parts and the
eyeballs were the same color and they're
not illuminated so I think it might just
be crummy visuals sorry but go and see
because that would be really interesting
and you asked me about the you mean the
physical design of the robot it's very
basic so the idea is that they studied
they watched many videos of adults
interacting with children whether they
were parents or you know daycare
providers in her lab they studied this
and this is a very kind of well-trod
trope in the psychology of child
development and they watched the way
that the the juveniles children right
would reproduce the emotive expression
of the adults no mirroring it and if you
read Cynthia Brazil's technical papers
she's looking at the psychology of
childhood development alongside this
kind of theory theorization of emotional
drives that darwin has presented which
is very basic and also infantilizing and
its basic conception of what is
primitive right so the idea is that
there's an evolutionary model of the
human and children reproduce a like
freud said right and so primitive human
equals juvenile child therefore darwin's
theory of drives should work for this
robot that's meant to be like a child
interacting with the caregiver so you
know in terms of the design of the
neural network if you want to call it
that it's based on six drives and the
robot is programmed to be easily upset
and it's programmed to want approval and
all of this is expressed through
eyebrows eye movement and then eyelids
for the most part it doesn't have much
of a face yeah let's go back to kiss me
so what's really interesting is then to
look at how social robotics and I can't
talk about this it's just a teaser gets
used in therapy for children who have
autism spectrum disorder and there used
to teach and kind of rationalize
effective performance and children who
have been who it's been decided aren't
doing this and so the idea is that
robots are very predictable and
repetitive and that this is helpful in
that kind of therapy and I don't have a
stance on it I haven't read all the
research but that's one direction that
this history has really gone into and
then I don't know am i taking up too
much time at doing this because I can
answer the surrogacy question too
because it's easy it's wrote a bunch of
articles that I would encourage you to
read where I kind of go through the
demographics and then there are other
studies that you know we've correlated
our data so at this clinic which is a
big one most of the women who come there
have come from the kind of wider region
but not further than when our two days
travel and have a range of education
levels but on average around what we
would call an eighth grade education
they come from all the castes in India
but are skewed towards lower castes and
are all women at this clinic and in even
in draft legislation it was mandated
that women should have already born one
child naturally naturally themselves and
this is both to test the viability of
their uterus also to on some level let's
imagine that this will prevent the
surrogate from wanting to keep the child
that she has so were there specific
other things you wanted to know yeah so
I mean one of the things that I and
other researchers and surrogacy talk
about is how women are encouraged to
live in hostels after their first
trimester away from their own children
and extended families so someone else is
taking care of their families in their
place and they're isolated for their own
good supposedly right but also for
surveillance so to rest but also to be
surveilled and this is something that's
shown to be very reassuring
commissioning parents
who know what's going on with the
gestation process so it's all it's all
out there in articles and books I'm
right the pen D has a book and shamela
read Rafa as well so in the back can you
say the last part again my sense is that
it's actually quite diverse in terms of
couples who and individuals who hire
surrogates I'm not actually I don't
study the u.s. so I'm not up to date on
the the scholarship but actually there's
an undergraduate here doing an honors
thesis on this you're a student right
Mary so we'll have to ask her as the
basis for
I left on you know and both the series
had a story it's all about this sort of
strange affinity between the
commissioning sort of ethics up here
yeah anything at all in that and so you
know anyway so unique thoughts about
where your thoughts about this sort of
strange affinities from convention yeah
I know it's a really interesting
question and this is something that I
don't have examples of that as exciting
as Octavia Butler's work where you know
isn't there a song by some mainstream
band called caring is creepy or
something I feel like that's getting it
to the you know like the strange
affinities that are also sometimes a
little like weird hair becomes creepy
but I you know the way I'm thinking
about it because what I really studied
is the relationship between law the
imaginary of biogenetics not even what's
really there in the data the imaginary
of biogenetics and then the social
reality of how we organize social
reproduction aka care here for today
what I'm looking at that sort of
triangle what I'm thinking about is how
does it get disrupted so that people can
try other things and so in the surrogacy
clinic the issue is we have the struggle
to maintain the rights and domain of the
nuclear family even though all these
other people involved because we have
egg donors sometimes sperm donors
definitely a gestational carrier we have
one often two legal individuals who
our position to have sole custody and
something like property rights to this
infant that will be born and so all of
this work is going into sustaining this
kind of idea of the nuclear family that
actually lives out through these
infrastructures right so how do we know
who the father is the missing father we
do a DNA test on Jerry Springer right
that whole thing is actually here in the
the clinic and so to me that argument to
answer your question I would say rather
than pointing to specific examples I
would think about what would it mean and
I asked this question with feminists
lawyers so I can tell you what the
answer was but what would it mean to
have a legal structure that protected
the relationship between a woman who
just stated and gave birth to a child
for another family to care for what
would it mean to have a relationship
between her community in that community
and would that be something that could
be legally protected and actually Laura
foster who is a feminist Science and
Technology scholar and has worked on the
patenting of individual them
technologies or knowledge --is in
different parts of Africa has worked
with different groups to actually sue
for property rights to practices that
have been passed down through
generations for cultivating specifically
her books about Hadiya for cultivating
and caring for a plant that actually
doesn't produce pharmacological results
without this very very specific kind of
care and propagation and the community
she was working with wanted to have not
just you know to be compensated for
their work and their you know the actual
plants but to have some kind of I would
call it intellectual property rights to
everything that comes out of that plant
and they succeeded so she told me about
this because there's a you know kind of
for me a legal interest in something
like that and so I wish you know I think
it would be more exciting and
interesting to think about the sort of
imaginations for possibility of what
other formations would look like but I
am someone who works with law and labor
and so for look at working with law and
labor what I'm thinking about is how can
we actually change laws
to redistribute the fruits of our labor
so that they support more people and
then aren't always channeled and another
story a colleague of mine had done one
of these again this is getting financial
and legal not very imaginary but a
colleague of mine had saved money in one
of these designated college savings
funds for a child that she lost and
wanted to give the savings to another
person who was going to college which
was the dedicated reason for having the
savings but legally could not because
this child wasn't her legal progeny so
there's this commitment to a kind of
social good that does not translate in
the legal realm so that's kind of what
I'm interested in finding out how people
have kind of transgressed in ways that
have done been incorporated back into
the law if that makes sense yeah
[Music]
in the other relationships you know like
you're taking they're like they're like
recommend Street for like maybe it was
interesting it like there's a
responsibility I don't even have to love
it you just do it because it's what
needs to be done so I need
interesting relationship it's
interesting like responsibility as which
would see like somebody commutes
together that we have even if you're
like oh my god I forgive you but you do
there a larger project of supporting
your students and their futures I think
it's an interesting model employer and a
yeah it is
I agree actually I would say that it is
a model for what I asked for at the end
which was you know do we have examples
for how we give up autonomy and a
feeling of superiority for the good of
something that's larger than us right
yeah
and it's uncomfortable I think it has to
be we see it a question
[Music]
her mother passed
as asking for responsibility
not only to the child but to her
and as Chakrabarti ideas about the
worker who confusion is also possible at
cultural meeting
what
yeah well I guess I've also written
about this but again I guess I'm just
I've been working with these feminist
organizations so much I immediately
translated that into how do we get
compensation for it but so what I was
going to say is that one of the things
that you'll find in my at mcgoofy but
also when other people have written
about conversations they've had with
surrogates as anthropologists is that
women say this thing that I did isn't
work it's not a job we don't want to
unionize in fact people who tried to
unionize surrogates and they don't in
general haven't it's changing want to be
unionized because of this very idea that
this isn't work it's something much more
important and you know the kind of
conversations that get repeated over and
over about this being exceeding even
like what humans can do for each other's
more like what God can do and of course
the clinic directors tell these stories
as a kind of example of the altruism of
the surrogates who are doing this
because they believe it's good not
because they are desperate for the money
or you know whatever the the fears are
of the commissioning parents so it's
tricky to separate what is the cultural
authentic you know feeling and in real
world view there from all the ways that
it plays out but what I would say is
that there's you know in the same way
that I took women at their word when
they said I know for a fact my body has
had a long-term impact on this child
that I gave birth to whether or not your
contract says it I know it then I went
to look for the science to you know to
back that up so I would say if someone
tells me what I did is far more than
money can compensate me for what I
really think is appropriate here is a
connection between our social worlds so
that if I get in trouble late are kind
of insurance right a kind of social
insurance then I say
the cultural and the thing that's
culturally important is that commitment
to a sense of this exceeding the labor
contract and and the entitlement should
be to some
the magnitude of the work yes well I it
is it's funny whenever Nita and I give
talks out of the surrogate Humanity book
there there always someone will bring up
the question of what about the fact that
technologies are often they feel like
they're mastering us right I'm
frustrated I don't understand what my
computer's in a bad mood today we
project all these things on tor
technologies and actually there's an
inter several interesting articles about
in feminist science technology studies
about how technologies make us serve
them sort of taking that perspective
that doesn't inform my work personally
but if you're interested so visions for
so let me see if I understand the
question what kind should ok I'm gonna
take out that which I didn't think could
so this is one that I happen to have
ready
a roboticist that came out of the same
lab as well not the same lab but the
same program is Cynthia Brazil which is
MIT Media Lab Cynthia Brazil was in
social robotics Kelly Dobson was in well
she was actually social robotics but she
worked with another mentor so Cynthia
Brazil's mentor was Roger books who's
really very famous in the creation of
intelligence artificial intelligence so
Omo with Kelly Dobson's robot which is
part of a larger project called machine
therapy and so Omo we argue and
surrogate humanity
something like a feminist robot that we
don't say that so what it is is and you
can find the video on youtube if you
want it's about this big orb it's got
this green kind of squishy coating on
the outside that feels a bit like skin
it has a little hole where air can go in
and out and it's composed of these
expandable ribs and a balloon inside
that can increase and decrease kind of
like our lungs when we breathe and the
program that runs it the kind of AI we
could call it it's very simple is
designed to respond to pressure stimulus
so if it feels something pressing on it
quickly or slowly it can respond by
expanding or contracting pressing back
quickly or slowly and she runs you in
her concept video she runs you through
how this object is meant to be
therapeutic for humans for animals and
for machines because it works on
frequencies from you know vibration
vibrational the speed of myth like a
washing machine vibration - like what a
mammal would produce through lung
capacity and it she makes a great point
of detailing the programming because it
is programmed to lead or follow a
pattern of breathing so it's not what
she calls a sort of obedient service
robot and she just opposes at - robots
like this Perl dinner spot which is I
guess a non feminist robot
definitely an on feminist robot so it's
a project between Carnegie Mellon and
the University of Pittsburgh and it's
meant actually it's kind of a prototype
for care robotics that would be used in
retirement facilities and skilled
nursing facilities and it it has very
basic functions it's it's functions are
it can just it can dispense
pharmaceuticals
it can take biometrics and it can
interact with you and this kind of
screen with a kind of survey that's not
unlike the one you get when you're
admitted to the hospital or when you go
for a check-up right how are you feeling
today are you in pain a scale of one to
ten so that's what it does but it's
imagined to replace nurses caregivers
companions adult children grandchildren
pets all these things that's how the
prototype is imagined so what dove scent
argues is this if it were ever out of
prototype and into a mass production
would drastically narrow the experience
and actually our kind of common sense of
what care can and should be between
humans because that's how infrastructure
works and so Omo is a critique it leads
and it follows it's meant to soothe but
not just to see that's got erotic
programming noise so it can sort of
misbehave at times it's not what she was
saying is not meant to model neuro
typicality so the idea is to disrupt
that feeling of autonomy by having
interdependence and that feeling of
mastery
it doesn't always obey so an example I
don't know if it's my ideal feminist
robot but it's definitely an interesting
one let's see other questions yet
I social so I guess I'm very good I mean
I guess I'm worried about the history of
the service and also the future which is
to say like how's the contract always
those are all really great questions I
mean I see why I mean they're about many
things the history so the history of the
contract when did it start
so the in the u.s. case law precedent is
that there were in some of the first
surrogacy cases the woman who was the
surrogate sued for custody so in the US
the reason the contract exists is to
protect the custodial rights of the
intending parents so in India that
precedent does not exist and so in India
the surrogacy contract looks very
different if you look at the actual
contracts and we never got to a point
where there was a nationally mandated
forum for the contract so that's one
thing
transnational surrogacy was banned at
the end of - 2016 and so there was never
a formal design for the contract also
the contract acted as a fiction in the
experience of most of the women who were
surrogates because they never saw it
they never got to keep a copy and they
it was not most of them were not in
positions where they could actually have
legal representation if they wanted to
sue for their rights under the contract
so it's a fiction that if anything would
protect the commissioning parents and
it's more of an informational document
meant to tell especially the
commissioning parents specifically what
their rights are and to tell the
surrogate what the expectations are for
example you get maintenance type
and each trimester until the delivery at
which point you get your actual payment
you get you don't get to decide about
abortions you don't get to decide how
many embryos to carry the term the
commissioning parents and the physician
get to decide so there are many things
like this that are in the contract and
it's used as an informational document
in that way for the surrogates but in
terms of actual legal efficacy and maybe
we can talk about the long history of
the labor contract afterwards very long
it goes back to indenture
[Applause]
[Music]